[Music]
the goal of the edicts project is to
provide prospective tenants with better
information about the expected costs of
heating and cooling prior to lease
signing and this project was motivated
by initial work that we did with first
low-income folks and then secondly
landlords and tenants which has a fairly
large overlap around energy use post
lease signing and so we focused in on a
issue that in a climate like Pittsburgh
is important to tenants postally signing
not fully evident in advertisements and
relates to our original interest in
energy use namely utility bills and it
takes a fair amount of effort to find
much information about utility bills
prior to lease signing and it's hard to
interpret that information and so we
tried to provide better information
about utility bills to prospective
tenants through the edicts website we
are very focused on Pittsburgh right now
because that's where our data is and
that's where we have on the ground
experience but we are collaborating with
a start-up a local startup called wrench
jungle that was founded by a CMU alum
and we're hoping that we'll be able to
deploy some of our software services
through that startup it is important to
individuals who are thinking about what
apartment to rent because it can impact
their bottom line and help them to be
more sustainable but it's also important
because of the way in which it leverages
multiple prospective tenants to collect
a new kind of data about apartments and
their utilities and their infrastructure
and it's also important because we're
dealing with a multi-stakeholder system
and if we can empower individuals to
consider these things we can begin to
provide a way of pressuring landlords
perhaps to think about upgrading their
infrastructure or providing better
services around energy use finally we
believe that the kind of data that we're
collecting can impact policymakers so we
hope to have an impact at multiple
levels with edicts
you